[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
24 ou 2019 un convoi de wagons
transportant des matières sèches des
rails à nantes une municipalité voisine
de lac mégantic
trois mois plus tard même scénario à
bolton ouest six wagons quitte les rails
et se renverse
[Musique]
ces deux déraillements ont un point en
commun ils sont survenus sur les rails
de la scène for men in québec louis
autrefois la mma est devenue une filiale
du canadien pacifique en décembre
dernier deux incidents qui ont ravivé le
sentiment d'insécurité des élus et de la
population que le taureau un événement
pour nous dit il ya d'autres ont été
chanceux mais ça fait encore une fois on
allume une lumière rouge
on faisait suite et or jean mais rien de
plus pour la première fois des employés
qui ont travaillé pour la mma et la cmq
air avant qu'il ne soit acquise par le
cp témoignent des pratiques qui étaient
en place au sein de l'entreprise pour
les protégés de possibles représailles
nous avons accepté qu'il témoigne sous
le couvert de l'anonymat
ils reviennent sur les événements de
l'an dernier les anomalies augmenté au
gaumont et ça finit que ça prend
beaucoup de temps avec sa soirée paris
c'est sûr que entretenir ses 170 km de
voies chat kutscher jacques wenders la
hyène n'est pas surpris par ces
affirmations
il connaît bien le milieu ferroviaire il
y a travaillé pendant des années et ce
un peu partout dans le monde depuis la
tragédie
il s'intéresse au sort réservé au rail
particulièrement à ceux de lac mégantic
en 2016 il était présent à une
conférence où le président d'entreprise
de présenter son plan d'investissement
sur cinq ans 22 millions de dollars
était prévu jusqu'à cette année pour
l'ensemble du réseau ferroviaire de ces
mqr dont plus de 300 kilomètres sont au
québec
ces montants sont nettement insuffisants
par rapport à l'emploi titanesque de la
voir réhabiliter ce n'est pas d'hier que
l'état der heide cmq air au québec
préoccupe un avis de transports canada
remis à la compagnie en mai 2019
démontre que depuis 2015
jamais le nombre de ride effectué n'a
été aussi grand transports canada écrit
même que la situation actuelle risque de
compromettre de façon imminente la
sécurité ferroviaire
l'organisme fédéral s'appuie sur ce
rapport d'inspection effectuées par un
de ses inspecteurs ferroviaire et dont
nous avons obtenu copie
du 29 avril au 1er mai 2019
ils repèrent plus de 190 défectuosité
sur les rails de la cmq air subdivision
sherbrooke
il note que la condition de plusieurs
traverse c'est aussi grandement dégradé
parmi elles celle ci qui croise la route
261 à nantes près de lac mégantic
transports canada demande à ce que le
tout soit réparé immédiatement ce que
confirme avoir fait cmq r
chrysler un train déraille à cet endroit
le 24 août dernier
nous sommes en train d'investiguer avec
thank u r qui avait fait des réparations
à cette section lot quatre jours avant
pourquoi le travail n'avait pas été
complétée compléter correctement c'est
pour le premier concert avec cette crème
est tendue ça faisait quelques années
qu'on en parle et puis éventuellement
est quelque chose qu elle arrivée là
quand passe lorsqu'on est le renvoyer
tout une anomalie mais qui du quai de
gare place faisait des années que cette
traverse était réputé problématique
depuis des années par l'entreprise ce
document interne démontre que dès avril
2010 est elle avait fait l'objet de
limitations de vitesse une mesure
temporaire prise lorsque des
défectuosités sont détectés deux ans
plus tard
des inspecteurs ferroviaire de ces mqr
soulève à nouveau un problème à cette
traverse une autre limitation de vitesse
est imposé arrive par la suite l'avis de
transports canada trois mois avant le
déraillement pas de prime bundle lève
c'est quoi v la traque leamy la traque
c'est une machine qui peut tout chaud en
même temps est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui coûte cher ce match nul c'est
celle là qui coûte le plus cher le
réseau géré au delà d'un côté l'entrevue
que nous avons sollicité à ce sujet
auprès de la cmq air est demeurée sans
réponse
partout sur le réseau de la cmq heures
les rails sont dangereuses des mesures
ont dû la voir
la coalition des citoyens et organismes
engagés pour la sécurité ferroviaire
réclame depuis des années des travaux
pour améliorer l'état des rails après le
déraillement de nantes
ils ont mis en demeure transports canada
et ministre des transports marc garneau
de faire cesser tout transport de
matières dangereuses sur les rails temps
que l'ensemble des réparations n'était
pas complété
le lendemain transports canada indique
avoir demandé à ses mqr d'effectuer les
réparations nécessaires
ce qu'elle aurait fait à sa satisfaction
deux mois plus tard la ville de
sherbrooke met en demeure la compagnie
ferroviaire
elle lui demande de corriger une
problématique qu'elle juge urgente sur
un tronçon situé sur son territoire en
janvier relationniste embauché par le cp
affirme que la compagnie considère qu'il
n'ya rien à réparer et aucun travaux à
faire transports canada avec l'autorité
il dirait hollande la cmq vont écouter
franchement là ça va plus ou bien vous
me remettez ça en état et quand ce sera
faible
on va faire une inspection tous ensemble
on va vous remettre votre beau mais
d'exploitation mentale en plus et ça
transforme canada non faussée par un pas
le courage aux autorités jak daxter sly
est née la coalition des citoyens et
organismes engagés pour la sécurité
ferroviaire ne sont pas les seuls à
demander à transports canada d'être plus
ferme avec les compagnies de chemin de
fer faute transports canada soit capable
sur la table quarante huit heures après
le déraillement bolton ouest le ministre
des transports du québec blanc mais
aussi ottawa pour l'impression qu'on
faisait le strict minimum pour s'assurer
que le réseau était viable sinon
réduisait la vitesse des wagons
nous avons sollicité une entrevue avec
le cp pour savoir quel réparations
avaient été faites sur le tronçon du
québec et combien d'argent elle avait
investi dans cette réfection depuis
l'acquisition de ces mqr on a refusé de
répondre à ces questions et décliné
notre demande d'entrevue par courriel
ont dit vouloir investir 90 millions de
dollars d'ici trois ans pour entretenir
les 870 km que compte le tronçon aux
états unis et au canada on ajoute que
des mesures correctrices ont été prises
afin de remédier à tous les défauts
identifiés à ce jour sur la voie de leur
côté les travailleurs du rail se croise
les doigts mais qu'on voit son plus
grand fait que la traque à part belle à
manger beaucoup
les convois sont effectivement plus
lourd de 2018 à 2019
le poids des chargements de wagons a
augmenté de 56% pour dire du pdg de ford
près ce week end des semaines
la société de portefeuille qui détient
alors c'est un put l'air de londres est
bien c'est que le transporteur phase d
inspection sérieuse et prennent à coeur
la mission transports canada cet index
conscience transports canada est au
service des citoyens canadiens et pas
autre chose
le ministre des transports marc garneau
a refusé notre demande d'entrevue
il simule sa future radio canada à
sherbrooke
[Applaudissements]